[Music]
you heard the travelers tales you
followed the crumbling maps and now
after a long and dangerous quest you
have some good news and some bad news
the good news is you've managed to
locate the legendary dungeon containing
the stash of ancient Stygian coins and
the eccentric wizard who owns the castle
has even generously agreed to let you
have them the bad news is that he's not
quite as generous about letting you
leave the dungeon unless you solve his
puzzle
the task sounds simple enough both
phases of each coin bear the fearsome
scorpion crest one in silver one in gold
and all you have to do is separate them
into two piles so that each has the same
number of coins facing silver side up
you're about to begin when all of the
torches suddenly blow out and you're
left in total darkness there are
hundreds of coins in front of you and
each one feels the same on both sides
you try to remember where the silver
facing coins were but it's hopeless
you've lost track but you do know one
thing for certain when there was still
light you counted exactly 20 silver side
up coins in the pile what can you do are
you doomed to remain in the dungeon with
your newfound treasure forever you're
tempted to kick the pile of coins and
curse the curiosity that brought you
here but at the last moment you stopped
yourself you just realized there's a
surprisingly easy solution what is it
you carefully move aside 20 coins one by
one it doesn't matter which once any
coins will do and then flip each one of
them over that's all there is to it why
does such a simple solution work well it
doesn't matter how many coins there are
to start with what matters is that only
20 of the total are facing silver side
up when you take 20 coins in the
darkness you have no way of knowing how
many of these silver facing coins have
ended up in your new pile but let's
suppose you got seven of them this means
that there are thirteen silver facing
coins left in the original pile it also
means that the other 13 coins in your
new pile are facing gold side up so what
happens when you flip all of the coins
in the new pile over seven gold facing
coins and thirteen silver facing coins
to match the ones in the original pile
it turns out this works no matter how
many of the silver facing coins you grab
whether it's all of them a few or none
at all that's because of what's known as
complementary events we know that each
coin only has two possible options if
it's not facing a silver side up it must
be gold side up and vice versa and in
any combination of 20 coins the number
of gold facing and silver facing coins
must add up to 20
we can prove this mathematically using
algebra the number of silver facing
coins remaining in the original pile
will always be 20 minus however many you
moved to the new pile and since your new
pile also has a total of 20 coins its
number of gold facing coins will be 20
minus the amount of silver facing coins
you moved when all the coins in the new
pile are flipped these gold facing coins
become silver facing coins so now the
number of silver facing coins in both
piles is the same
the gate swings open and you hurry away
with your treasure before the wizard
changes his mind at the next crossroads
you flip one of your hard-earned coins
to determine the way to your next
adventure but before you go we have
another quick coin riddle for you one
that comes from this video sponsors
excellent website here we have eight
arrangements of coins you can flip over
adjacent pairs of coins as many times as
you like a flip always changes gold to
silver and silver to gold can you figure
out how to tell at a glance which
arrangements can be made
all gold you can try an interactive
version of this puzzle and confirm your
solution on brilliants website we love
brilliant work because the site gives
you tools to approach problem solving in
one of our favorite ways by breaking
puzzles into smaller pieces or limited
cases and working your way up from there
this way you're building up a framework
for problem solving instead of just
memorizing formulas you can sign up for
brilliant for free and if you like
riddles a brilliant org premium
membership will get you access to
countless more interactive puzzles try
it out today by visiting brilliant org
slash ted-ed and use that link so they
know we sent you the first 833 of you to
visit that link will receive 20% off the
annual premium subscription fee
[Music]